Na, heute schon was Schönes erlebt im Traum?
Eigentlich sind Träume doch irgendwie der Ort,
wo nichts klappt wie man will, oder?
Man versucht wegzulaufen und es geht nicht.
Man schreit und es hört einen niemand.
Aber jetzt stellt euch mal vor, ihr könntet im Traum
alles erleben, was ihr wollt.
Das ist das Versprechen von luzidem Träumen.
Es ist die Idee,
dass wir unsere Träume nicht nur bewusst erleben,
sondern manchmal sogar steuern können.
Ist eine unglaublich geile Vorstellung, oder?
Und ich will das können.
Ich will im Traum fliegen.
Ich will Neuseeland wiedersehen
und tatsächlich vielleicht auch mal eine
bestimmte Person küssen.
Ich meine, warum nicht?
Ich will innerhalb von drei Wochen lernen, luzide zu träumen.
Dafür brauche ich Hilfe.
Und die hole ich mir von einer, die es schon kann.
Und von einem, der es erforscht.
Es gibt ja schon ein paar Infos im Netz über Klarträume,
aber ich will wissen, was sagt denn die Wissenschaft?
Und ich verspreche euch, am Ende dieses Videos
werdet ihr alle Werkzeuge an der Hand haben,
um schon heute Nacht luzide träumen zu können.
Klarträumen ist wirklich möglich.
Seit den 60er Jahren wird es auch wissenschaftlich untersucht.
Klarträumen bedeutet vor allen Dingen erstmal,
sich darüber bewusst zu werden,
dass man träumt, während man träumt.
Erst im zweiten Schritt kommt dann die Kontrolle.
Für meine Spurensuche will ich erst mal mit jemandem quatschen,
der schon luzide träumen kann, nämlich mit Caro.
Sie hat sich das Klarträumen selbst beigebracht
und ich hoffe,
dass sie noch ein paar Tipps hat für mich.
Hallo!
- Hi.
Freut mich sehr, dass du dir Zeit nimmst.
Danke für die Einladung.
- Sehr gerne. Wollen wir ein Stück spazieren?
Caro, wann hattest du denn deinen ersten Klartraum?
Das muss schon mit sechs, sieben Jahren gewesen
sein.
So früh schon? Krass.
- Ja.
Was ist da passiert?
Also es hatte in dieser Zeit eine Phase, wo ich ganz viele Alpträume hatte.
Und zwar habe ich ständig geträumt,
dass ich in meinem Kinderzimmer wach werde
und es hat auf einmal gebrannt.
Also gerade so bei den Fenstern
und ich konnte die Tür nicht öffnen.
Irgendwann in diesem selben Traum
bin ich mir dann halt bewusst geworden,
dass ich gerade träume.
Wow, krass.
- Genau, das war so das erste Mal.
Und dann?
- Dann hat sich der Traum halt auch total verändert.
Ich habe mich dann entschieden, durch dieses Feuer durchzugehen.
Auf einmal war alles so total kitzelig irgendwie.
Ich konnte noch so zur "kleinen Heldin" werden,
weil ich halt meine Familie noch retten konnte.
Geil. Und wie ist es heute?
Also machst du das jetzt so ganz aktiv?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe tatsächlich diese Fähigkeit irgendwie
so ein bisschen verloren,
als ich dann erwachsen geworden bin.
Und habe dann vor sechs Jahren, als ich selber so
gesundheitliche Probleme hatte
und wieder viele Albträume.
Dann habe ich mich bewusst
entschieden, dass ich das halt wieder lernen will.
Was machst du so?
Man kann sich ja theoretisch alles vorstellen:
Mal ins Weltall, die Tiefsee erkunden,...
Das Fliegen, der Klassiker.
- Genau. Das Fliegen auf jeden Fall.
Das macht halt saumäßig Spaß.
- Ja? Wie geil!
Das kann halt auch einfach nur so zum Spaß sein.
Es wäre so cool jetzt einfach loszufliegen.
Ja, als Kind habe ich wirklich einfach so...
Wie man sich das als Kind vorstellt, einfach so mit den Armen.
Dann konnte ich halt auf einmal fliegen und fand es total cool.
Wie hast du das geschafft?
Das ist jetzt meine große Frage.
- Das große Geheimnis.
Also das allerwichtigste ist wirklich,
dass du dich an deine Träume erinnern kannst.
Da fängt es bei mir schon an,
das kann ich nämlich selten.
Ja, das geht ganz vielen so
und deswegen ist der ultimative Tipp Nummer eins,
ein Traumtagebuch zu schreiben.
Damit schulst du einfach dieses Traumgedächtnis.
Umso mehr du dich an deine Träume erinnern kannst,
umso mehr fällt dir auch auf,
was vielleicht wiederkehrt in den Träumen
und was dann irgendwie im Nachhinein betrachtet
doch ein bisschen seltsam ist.
Damit ich mir bewusst werde:
"Moment, da stimmt was nicht."
oder: "Das habe ich doch schon mal geträumt."
Und dann wird mir der Traum bewusst?
-  Ja, genau.
Also du schreibst das einfach immer auf,
sobald du wach wirst.
Egal, wenn das mitten in der Nacht
ist, das schreibst du alles in dein Traumtagebuch.
Okay. Mache ich. Kaufe ich mir heute noch.
Was kann ich sonst noch tun?
Du kannst sogenannte Realitätschecks
durchführen.
Dass du deine Hand ganz intensiv betrachtest
und die Finger zählst,
ob da wirklich fünf dran sind.
Weil es im Traum nicht so ist, oder wieso?
Genau. Im Traum kann es nämlich passieren,
dass du auf einmal sieben Finger hast.
Ah, krass!
Oder dass die Hand halt so verschwimmt,
dass du deinen Finger durchbohren kannst.
Das kann auch im Traum alles möglich sein, weil
da bist du ja im Raum der unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten.
Das klingt so gut!
Du gehst halt schon mit der Intention ins Bett,
dass du heute Nacht klarträumst.
Gerade wenn du das am Anfang lernen willst,
ist das auch total wichtig,
dass du dich ins Bett legt und dir sagst: "Heute Nacht werde ich klarträumen."
Und ganz fest daran glauben.
Das soll helfen. Das hat bei dir geklappt.
Das hat bei mir geklappt.
Vielen Dank, Caro. Ich werde deine Tipps
auf jeden Fall versuchen anzuwenden.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass du das schaffen wirst.
Diese Fähigkeit hat jeder Mensch. Wir werden damit geboren.
Die meisten vergessen es einfach nur irgendwann.
Du hast mich erinnert.
I'll try my best.
Ich bin jetzt super neugierig und will es
unbedingt ausprobieren und hoffe, das klappt.
Mein Traumziel ist, dass ich über Neuseeland fliegen will.
Das wäre so geil.
Ich erinnere mich ehrlich gesagt
super selten überhaupt an meine Träume.
Und Studien zeigen, je seltener man sich an seine Träume erinnert,
desto seltener kann man auch Klarträumen.
Macht ja auch Sinn. Aber das soll sich verbessern.
Ich mache jetzt drei Wochen Challenge.
Ich führe Traumtagebuch,
ich mache meine Realitätscheck und ich werde
mir immer wieder sagen: "Ich werde Klarträumen."
Also ich bin gespannt.
Wettet ihr für mich oder gegen mich?
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare.
Die Fähigkeit haben laut Studien Kinder öfter.
Sie geht nur dann scheinbar wieder verloren.
Aber immerhin jede*r zweite hat es schon mal erlebt
und jede*r fünfte macht es sogar regelmäßig.
Also ich würde sagen, ich starte jetzt mit Caros Tipps durch.
Ab ins Bett.
Ich werde heute Nacht klarträumen.
Ich werde mich erinnern, dass ich träume.
Ich werde mir bewusst sein, dass ich träume.
Ich werde heute Nacht klarträumen.
So, ihr Lieben, ich will ja lernen, luzide zu träumen
und ich habe meine Tipps bekommen.
Also habe ich hier schon dieses süße
kleine Tagebuch
und werde jetzt heute Nacht anfangen,
meine Träume aufzuschreiben.
Was da dann so bei rauskommt, was hier so drinsteht,
ihr werdet auf jeden Fall davon erfahren.
Also unser Schlaf ist untergliedert
in verschiedene Phasen
und die durchlaufen wir pro Nacht zyklisch.
Die meisten Träume finden dabei in einer
speziellen Phase statt, nämlich in der REM-Phase.
In dieser Phase sind Teile unseres Nervensystems
ziemlich aktiv.
Die Amygdala und der Thalamus senden
ganz viele Signale.
Im Traum erleben wir dadurch Sinne,
Farben, Gefühle und Bewegung.
Unser Körper bewegt sich aber nicht,
weil unsere Muskeln gelähmt sind,
außer die Muskeln unserer Augen.
Deshalb bewegen sich unsere Augen
ganz schnell hin und her.
Deswegen sagt man auch REM-Schlaf für "Rapid Eye Movement".
Wie kann ich denn jetzt aber beweisen,
dass jemand in diesem Zustand ein Klartraum hat?
Dann muss er mir das ja irgendwie mitteilen,
während ich sehe, dass er noch schläft.
Aber wie soll man mit einem kommunizieren,
der schläft?
Die Forschenden haben mit den Proband*innen
quasi ein Signal ausgemacht, und zwar
ein bestimmtes Muster von Augenbewegungen.
Nach dem Motto: Wenn ich zwei mal nach links schaue
und einmal nach rechts,
dann habe ich grade einen Klartraum.
Wenn die Forschenden also diesen Morsecode
gesehen haben und gleichzeitig gesehen haben,
der schläft noch - was man an den Hirnströmen sehen kann -
dann wussten sie, obwohl er schläft,
ist er bei Bewusstsein. Ist doch cool, oder?
Aber wie kann das sein, dass das Hirn quasi gleichzeitig schlafend und wach ist?
Während wir schlafen, kann man mit dem EEG ganz bestimmte Hirnströme messen.
Man sieht dabei auch, dass der präfrontale
Cortex quasi nicht aktiv ist.
Das ist auch bei normalen Träumen so,
aber nicht bei Klarträumen.
Da kann man sehen, dass Teile unseres Vorderhirns
plötzlich ungewöhnlich aktiv sind.
Sie schwingen so im Bereich von 40 Hz,
was eigentlich typisch für den Wachzustand ist.
Das sind Teile unseres Gehirns,
die eine Rolle spielen
für kritisches Denkvermögen, für Urteilsfähigkeit
und für unser Bewusstsein.
Unser Bewusstsein erwacht also quasi,
während wir schlafen und während wir träumen.
Damit werden wir uns auch bewusst
darüber, dass wir träumen.
Leider hilft mir dieses Wissen gerade nicht dabei, es auch in die Tat umzusetzen.
Ich glaube, ich brauche noch mehr Tipps.
Ich frage jemanden, der sich wissenschaftlich
mit luziden Träumen beschäftigt.
Vielen Dank, Martin, dass du mich noch mal
von der wissenschaftlichen Seite beraten willst.
Bei mir klappt es nämlich
noch nicht so richtig mit dem luziden Träumen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich mach vielleicht etwas falsch.
Kannst du mir noch einen richtig guten Tipp
geben, was ich tun kann?
Also eine Methode, die auch so mit Hausmitteln
machbar ist,
ist ein Wecker, den ich einfach in den frühen Morgenstunden, in den späten Nachtstunden
um vier, fünf Uhr mir den Wecker stelle und mich selbst aufwecke.
Also das "Wake Back to Bed", dass ich mich mal in den frühen Morgenstunden wecke
und dann eine halbe Stunde, eine Stunde wach bleibe in dieser Zeit.
Ein bisschen noch über meinen letzten Traum nachdenke und
dann wieder zurück in den Schlaf gehe.
Der Grund, warum das die Chance eines Klartraum deutlich erhöht,
ist, dass ein aktivierter präfrontaler Cortex,
also die Hirnregion direkt hinter der Stirn,
auf eine REM Schlafphasen trifft.
REM Schlaf ist die Schlafphasen, wo wir am häufigsten Klarträume haben,
die aber vor allem
in den späten Nachtstunden auftritt
und die normalerweise mit einem deutlich
deaktivierten präfrontalen Cortex verbunden ist.
Diese Kombination aus einem wieder aktivierten präfrontalen
Cortex
und einer REM Schlafphase,
das ist eine Kombination, die sich als sehr wirksam erwiesen hat,
um Klarträume zu beeinflussen oder zu erzeugen.
Ist das Klarträumen denn wirklich nur eine Sache,
die man macht, weil man Spaß haben will?
Oder hat das auch noch einen Mehrwert?
Also es gibt tatsächlich verschiedene praktische
und auch klinische Anwendungen des Klarträumens.
Praktische Anwendungen insbesondere im Sport.
Man kann verschiedene Bewegungsabläufe
im Schlaf trainieren, im Traum trainieren
und da gibt es durchaus
Studien, die zeigen, dass das funktionieren kann.
Es gibt auch Umfragen unter Sportler*innen,
die zeigen, dass tatsächlich auch ein Prozentsatz
von professionellen Athleten das einsetzt,
insbesondere für Risiko-Sportarten.
Im klinischen Bereich wird das Klarträumen
insbesondere als Albtraum-Therapie eingesetzt.
Wenn ich während eines Albtraums realisiere, dass das Ganze nicht echt ist,
dass das nur ein Traum ist, dann nimmt das natürlich viel von dem Schrecken.
Wenn ich gerade von einem Monster gejagt werde
und dann merke: Moment, das bilde ich mir nur ein.
Dann kann ich einfach stehen bleiben und das Monster umarmen oder einfach ignorieren oder ähnliches.
Ich glaube, ich werde deinen Tipp jetzt auf jeden Fall noch versuchen, die "Wake Back to Bed" Methode.
Ich werde dir mal berichten, wie es gelaufen ist.
Ich drück die Daumen.
- Danke schön, vielen Dank.
Wenn ich meine Träume kontrollieren will und weiß, dass ich vor allem in der REM Schlafphase träume
und die eben ganz frühmorgens am längsten sind,
dann muss tatsächlich in aller Frühe der Wecker klingeln.
Jetzt schon kein Bock.
Aber ich mach das jetzt, weil es ist schließlich wissenschaftlich approved.
Eine große australische Studie hat gezeigt,
dass genau diese Kombination
aus Realitätscheck und der "Wake Back to Bed" Methode zusammen mit mnemonischer Induktion -
Also praktisch, dass ich mir kurz vorher nochmal sage:
"Jetzt werde ich klarträumen" - dass das am besten funktioniert hat.
In der Studie tatsächlich bei 17% der Proband*innen innerhalb von einer Woche,
also muss ja wohl auch bei mir klappen, oder?
Ich werde heute Nacht klarträumen.
Ich werde mich erinnern, dass ich träume.
Kleines Update: kein Klartraum, nix passiert.
Und das obwohl ich jetzt diese Methode anwende,
wo ich mich dann morgens wecken lasse,
um mir dann nochmal zu sagen: Jetzt träumst du klar.
Aber nein, tu ich nicht.
Ja, wenn ich am Schreibtisch sitze und müde bin deshalb,
ist das natürlich durchaus frustrierend,
weil ich es echt gerne schaffen würde.
Auf der anderen Seite muss ich schon sagen,
dass ich auf jeden Fall mehr träume
oder mich zumindest mehr erinnere.
Also heut Nacht habe ich zum Beispiel so einen Quatsch geträumt.
Irgendwie war ich selbst Busfahrerin mit einer Freundin, also weirdes Zeug.
Auf jeden Fall ist es mir jetzt bewusster
und ich finde,
das ist für mich schon ein krasser Fortschritt,
weil ich echt jahrelang
so gut wie nix gefühlt geträumt habe,
zumindest nix davon wusste.
Also weiter fingers crossed. I'll keep you posted.
Ich hab noch nicht mal geschafft, mir im Traum bewusst zu werden, dass ich träume.
Geschweige denn mich selbst zu steuern, dass ich zum Beispiel fliege
oder den ganzen Trauminhalt zu verändern, dass ich quasi in Neuseeland wär.
Laut einer Studie, schaffen auch nur 2/3 derjenigen, die überhaupt klarträumen,
sich selbst zu steuern und nur die Hälfte verändern dann auch den ganzen Trauminhalt.
Also es könnte für mich echt noch ein weiter Weg sein,
aber einer der sich mehr lohnen könnte als ihr denkt.
Einige Neurowissenschaftler*innen gehen davon aus, dass Träume
quasi wie so ein mentales Trainingsprogramm sind.
In der Vergangenheit könnten sie uns geholfen haben,
mit gefährlichen Situationen besser klarzukommen,
weil wir die quasi im Traum schon mal durchgespielt hätten
und dann in der Realität besser damit klarkommen.
Wie man sich zum Beispiel am besten verhält, wenn ein Tiger neben einem steht,
hätten wir dann eben schon im Traum gelernt.
Das wäre dann ein echter evolutionärer Vorteil gewesen.
Heute würden wir dann wahrscheinlich eher gefährliche soziale Situation schon mal durchproben.
Die psychologische Traumforschung, die geht davon aus, dass wir Träume genau so nutzen.
Um schon mal vorab zu checken, wie man sich am
besten in sozialen Situationen verhalten sollte.
Wenn wir dann nämlich merken, wenn wir aufgewacht sind,
oh je das war peinlich oder nicht so cool,
- wie wenn wir geträumt haben, dass wir nackt sind oder so -
dann lassen wir das in der Realität lieber bleiben.
Also, dass die Forschung zeigt, dass luzides Träumen nicht nur so "just for fun" geil ist,
sondern mir sogar helfen kann, meine Probleme zu lösen.
Dass ich kreativ werden kann oder alles trainieren
kann, was ich will und das im Schlaf.
Das pusht mich jetzt echt noch mal mehr, dass ich
einfach konsequent dranbleibe und weiter übe.
Ich habe jetzt schon fast knapp drei Wochen mein Traumtagebuch geführt,
Realitätscheck gemacht, mir immer wieder gesagt,
dass ich Klarträumen werde
und mich sogar in aller Frühe wecken lassen.
Müsste das nicht endlich mal Früchte tragen?
Es ist erst 7 Uhr, aber ich muss euch unbedingt was erzählen.
Und zwar ist heut Nacht was krasses passiert,
oder vielmehr gerade eben:
Ich war tatsächlich in Neuseeland in meinem Traum.
Es war super cool. Ich war genau an dem Ort, wo ich auch gewohnt habe.
Ich habe genau die Bucht erkannt
und alles war total detailliert. Wunderschön.
Also es war kein Klartraum, aber es war gefühlt schon nahe dran.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich nähere mich.
Mein Fazit: Ganz so einfach ist es nicht mit dem luziden Träumen.
Zumindest nicht für mich.
Aber falls ihr euch eh schon öfter an eure Träume
erinnert,
kann es für euch auch viel einfacher sein.
Und ich sage mal so: Die Tipps von Caro und Martin
sind ja auf jeden Fall die, die wissenschaftlich
erwiesen zum Erfolg führen können.
Also heißt es vielleicht einfach
konsequent sein und dranbleiben, bis auch ich irgendwann über Neuseeland fliege.
Auf jeden Fall könnte es für jede*n von euch schon heute Nacht so weit sein.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall weitermachen. Ich finde die Vorstellung immer noch so geil.
Ich sage mal so: Es ist doch, wie ein berühmter Schlafforscher mal gesagt hat:
Wenn wir schon ein Drittel unseres Lebens schlafen müssen,
warum dann auch noch, während wir träumen?
Übrigens, dass wir uns heute mit dem luziden Träumen beschäftigt haben,
das war tatsächlich ein Wunsch von euch, aus der Community.
Falls ihr noch mehr Themenideen habt, packt die sehr gerne mal an die Kommentare.
Natürlich auch, ob die Tipps bei euch geklappt haben
und was ihr so Schönes geträumt habt.
Wenn ihr noch ein bisschen weiter schauen wollt,
dann haben wir hier noch ein weiteres Video
über Bewusstseinszustände
und da wäre noch eins von reporter, da geht es um Schlafparalyse.
Und natürlich freue ich mich wie immer über ein Abo.
Schauen wir mal: Sind wir im Traum oder nicht?
Nee, doch wieder nicht.
Nur die schnöde Realität.